[Música]
se mantiene la tensión entre Francia e
Italia después del rechazo italiano de
recibir el barco
inmigrantes a bordo y que finalmente
tuvo que atracar en las costas francesas
este país intensificó los controles
fronterizos con Italia
cerca de 200 agentes de la policía
ucraniana ocuparon el centro de la
ciudad de gerson tras el repliegue de
las tropas rusas Mientras tanto Rusia
insiste en que el retiro de las tropas
no cambia el estatus de esta región que
ya fue anexada a la federación de Rusia
y controversia en Bolivia después de la
decisión del presidente Luis Arce de
mantener el censo de población para el
2024 y no realizarlo en el 2023 como lo
estaban pidiendo los manifestantes todo
esto de cara para las elecciones
generales del 2025 lo que ampliaría la
cuota de diputados y también la cantidad
de recursos estatales
muy buenas noches Bienvenidos a las
noticias de France 24 soy Santiago López
González Gracias por estar con nosotros
a esta hora vamos a comenzar en Europa
las relaciones entre Francia e Italia
están en un momento tenso tras la
decisión del gobierno de la primera
ministra Georgia meloni de no recibir al
barco lleno de migrantes Ocean bike
viking que terminó llegando finalmente a
costas francesas el gobierno del
presidente de Manuel majó a
intensificado los controles fronterizos
entre los dos países para evitar entre
otras cosas el aumento del contrabando
cerca de las ciudades de mantón y
ventimiglia en la frontera Franco
italiana se intensifican los controles
los guardias fronterizos y la policía
están deteniendo a los coches
procedentes de Italia nos piden que
abramos el maletero y revisan nuestras
identificaciones las tensiones entre
Francia e Italia aumentan a causa del
Ocean biking un barco con 230
inmigrantes que finalmente ha podido
atracar en Tulum el Ministerio del
interior francés ha desplegado 500
agentes más para ayudar a realizar las
inspecciones fronterizas en la región el
refuerzo de estos chequeos implica
mayores esperas para los conductores
creo que Francia hace bien en limitar un
poco a todos estos inmigrantes que
vienen aquí y creo que cuando la policía
está aquí no puede estar allí hay otras
tareas más importantes para ellos que
permanecer en un puesto fronterizo
Los contrabandistas también son buscados
en estos controles desde principios de
años se ha detenido a 680 de ellos a
pesar de la posibilidad de cinco años de
cárcel y 300.000 euros de multas y son
detenidos su número va en aumento
Los contrabandistas pueden ser guías en
los senderos pueden ser personas que van
a buscar en vehículos privados pero
también pueden ser robos en camiones de
transporte
otro foco la estación de tren de
mantonga gabán
el tren de cercanías que viene de Italia
espera 15 minutos más
[Música]
pasaporte por favor el retraso molesta
algunos pasajeros estoy en contra de
este tipo de control dificulta la libre
circulación los automovilistas y
pasajeros de tren que se dirijan a la
frontera tendrán que acostumbrarse a
esperas más largas ya que se prevé que
la situación no cambia en los próximos
días después de La retirada de las
tropas rusas avanza la retoma ucraniana
en la ciudad de gerson en la jornada de
hoy unos 200 policías ingresaron a la
ciudad y volvieron a emitir las
estaciones de radio y la televisión
ucraniana Mientras tanto en el kremlin
insisten en que el retiro de las tropas
no cambia el estatus de la región que ya
fue anexada de manera unilateral a Rusia
la celebración de una reconquista El
regreso del ejército ucraniano a la
ciudad de gerson ha sido catalogado como
la mayor victoria de kiev desde que
inició la invasión hace ocho meses Rusia
dijo que retiró a más de 30.000
militares de la urbe hacia la otra
orilla del río nipera
los ciudadanos de gerson esperaron nunca
repudiaron a Ucrania tenían razón al
depositar sus esperanzas en Ucrania y
Ucrania siempre devuelve las suyas me
alegra ver a esa gente a pesar de todos
los peligros la represión y el
sufrimiento infligido por los ocupantes
que se aferran a las banderas ucranianas
en el centro de kiev cientos se
reunieron el viernes por la noche para
celebrar la noticia muchos son
originarios de gerson pero que huyeron
cuando las fuerzas rusas los invadieron
en marzo
Ginger son muchos empiezan a regresar a
sus hogares o lo que queda de ellos los
rusos destruyeron y saquearon casas pero
no todo se fueron como esta granjera que
recuerdan los angustiosos momentos que
vivió durante la ocupación
no el camino
nos van con las culatas de los rifles
los rusos dañaron las casas de luz que
sirvieron a su ejército y se llevaron
los bienes de las mejores casas
jerson fue la única gran ciudad
ucraniana en caer en manos enemigas
Rusia sigue controlando alrededor del
60% de la región que lleva el mismo
nombre incluida la costa del mar de azul
y que fue anexionada ilegalmente junto a
otras tres por Moscú el principal punto
de acceso a la ciudad cruzando el río
nieper era el puente anthonynski ahora
destruido según lo confirmado por
imágenes satelitales imágenes que
también señalan nuevos daños en La
Represa de Nueva kahofka al norte de
gerson y cuya eventual voladura
generaría desastrosas inundaciones en el
país
y es uno de los grandes temas a los que
se están enfrentando los líderes de la
asea la asociación de Naciones del
sudeste asiático justamente es la crisis
política en Mia al mar desde el golpe de
estado perpetrado por los militares en
febrero del 2021 la junta militar que
gobierna este país se mantiene alejada
de los principales escenarios
internacionales sobre todo de Cumbres de
la asean y en particular de esta que
tiene lugar en Camboya
Camboya es la penúltima parada del viaje
Express del presidente estadounidense en
el centro de los debates La amenaza
nuclear norcoreana pero también Taiwán y
China un preludio de la reunión entre
Joe biden y shiggins bally dentro de
unos días en el marco del g20 otro tema
importante el estancamiento de la crisis
en yanmark el líder de la junta no fue
invitado por segundo año consecutivo una
ausencia que delata la falta de avances
en las conversaciones para resolver la
crisis
los líderes asiáticos y el secretario
general de la ONU afirman que la junta
no va a cumplir sus objetivos de
restablecer la paz
de violencia el uso desproporcionado de
la fuerza y la terrible situación de los
Derechos Humanos en mi al mar los
ataques indiscriminados contra civiles
pueden constituir crímenes de guerra
según el derecho internacional
este año la asociación de Naciones del
sur está asiático va más allá los
líderes quieren involucrar a los grupos
de oposición de myanmar en el proceso de
paz esto ha provocado La era de la junta
gobernante que considera sus opositores
como terroristas las organizaciones
humanitarias también denuncian las
acciones de la junta
Por las luchas geopolíticas entre
Estados Unidos y China sobre la cuestión
de myanmar pero los dirigentes se
olvidan de que miles de personas han
perdido la vida a manos de esta junta
diabólica Y seguirán perdiéndola
mientras las sean siga paralizada
no es conocida por sus posturas
televisivas pero este año se está
endureciendo e incluso se está
considerando excluir a los
representantes de myanmar por completo
si la situación lo justifica vamos a
hablar ahora de noticias de nuestro
continente Vamos hasta Estados Unidos
para ver cómo avanza el recuento de los
resultados de las votaciones de esas
elecciones de medio término en este país
norteamericano mientras los republicanos
están a siete escaños de lograr la
mayoría de la cámara de representantes
los demócratas necesitan solo un escaño
para hacerse con el control del senado
es decir la cámara alta allí justamente
la cámara alta cuentan ambos partidos
con 49 senadores por lo que la atención
está puesta en ese recuento que está
teniendo lugar en el estado de Nevada
que es el único estado que todavía no ha
oficializado la totalidad de los
resultados una victoria demócrata en
Nevada les daría Entonces al partido del
presidente joviten el control del senado
contando con el de desempate de la
vicepresidenta kamala Harris una
situación que mantendría prácticamente
el mismo escenario en la cámara alta que
había antes de estas elecciones de medio
término
y seguimos en Estados Unidos porque dos
aviones de guerra antiguos chocaron en
pleno vuelo durante un espectáculo aéreo
en un aeropuerto Ejecutivo en la ciudad
de Dallas esto en el estado de Texas de
acuerdo con las autoridades locales e
indicaron que hubo víctimas entre el
público que estaba presenciando este
espectáculo aéreo pero no dieron mayores
detalles sobre los tripulantes de los
dos aviones algunos de los restos de los
fuselajes de estas aeronaves cayeron en
una concurrida autopista cercana que
tuvo que ser cerrada al tránsito ya
comenzó una investigación sobre este
accidente por parte de las autoridades
federales de Aviación
nos vamos ahora hasta el Sur del
continente en Bolivia este viernes el
presidente Luis Arce mantuvo el censo
poblacional para el 2024 lo que
mantendría entonces el registro actual
para las próximas elecciones la
oposición protesta en las calles de la
ciudad de Santa Cruz ya que piden que el
censo se renueve en 2023 de esta manera
pueden disponer con más recursos incluso
más diputados para los comicios que
están previstos para el 2025 el informe
es de lluis Muñoz
la atención se mantienen las calles de
Santa Cruz mientras el gobierno
boliviano no da su brazo a torcer y
mantiene el censo poblacional y de
vivienda para el 23 de marzo de 2024 el
presidente Luis Arce hizo un llamado a
la calma las bolivianas y bolivianos
queremos vivir en paz somos de la
cultura del diálogo y de la paz y por
eso llamamos a pacificar entre todas y
todos
el viernes se cumplían tres semanas de
protestas
es el plazo que dio la oposición de
Santa Cruz para convocar el censo
poblacional en 2023 Durante este tiempo
ha habido cuatro muertos y más de 100
heridos se acaben
los resguarda la violencia a nuestra
gente
y que estén con el pueblo que es lo que
Todos queremos el último centro se
realizó en 2012 el gobierno de Luis Arce
lo retrasó de 2023 a 2024 alegando el
parón de la pandemia además de bastión
opositor Santa Cruz es la segunda ciudad
del país y el principal centro económico
es la mayor receptora de migración
interna por lo que el aumento de
población le otorgaría más recursos de
hacerse el censo en 2023 la región
tendría tres diputados más en la
asamblea para las elecciones de 2025 Sin
embargo esta protesta se limita a Santa
Cruz y no tiene apoyo en el resto del
país tampoco es un apoyo masivo de forma
interna Ya que el movimiento al
socialismo es el segundo partido más
apoyado en la región
no nos dejan circular no nos dejan pagar
No nos deja hacer nada Santa Cruz fue
también en 2019 el lugar desde donde se
ideó el derrocamiento del gobierno de
Evo Morales
vamos a seguir en Bolivia porque allí la
hoja de coca es un símbolo ancestral que
especialmente es utilizada en las zonas
Rurales donde más se consume con las
migraciones internas los grandes núcleos
urbanos ven un Boom en su consumo esto
también ha llegado incluso hasta las
élites y también ha disparado la
industria en el interior del país
en las zonas Rurales de Bolivia más
carcoca es parte de la vida misma y esto
se está extendiendo cada vez más a las
ciudades que con esta apropiación
también acaban con el estigma
beneficiándose de las propiedades de la
planta ancestral hoy en día lo consumen
todo de
doctores policías es como energizante
natural alivia mucho el estrés y se
quita te quita mucho
el cansancio este Boom tiene especial
peso en Santa Cruz la segunda ciudad de
Bolivia es el principal centro económico
y de recepción de migrantes los locales
al ver los efectos que tiene la coca en
los indígenas se han acercado a su
consumo y cada vez hay más iniciativas
desde saborizantes como la maracuyá
sofisticados brebajes y llega hasta las
exclusivas fiestas de la ciudad hay
mucho mucha gente en Santa Cruz hay una
gente que en camba tradicional
así está el su popularidad que ha
llegado a las esferas de la fama como
Daniel Novoa conocido como boloman con
más de 200.000 seguidores en tiktok con
vídeos humorísticos sobre la coca en la
mayoría
quizás todo no son menos en los que no
estoy volando el mercado de la coca solo
puede crecer en Bolivia la hoja
ancestral está clasificada como
substancia controlada por las Naciones
Unidas sin embargo Bolivia pudo crear
una excepción por la importancia de la
coca en el país ya avanza la Cumbre
climática cop27 que tiene lugar en la
ciudad de charmershake en Egipto la
jornada de hoy estuvo marcada por el
premio fósil nuestra enviada especial
Marina Colorado nos cuenta más detalles
en su reporte
una tradición desde 1999 en las cumbres
climáticas que desgraciadamente cada vez
es más relevante el premio al fósil del
día una galardón sarcástico que entrega
la red de acción por el clima a los
países que más hacen para avanzar lo
menos posible en la lucha contra el
cambio climático el primero en recibir
este galardón en la co27 fue Japón por
ser el país con el gobierno que mayor
inversión pública hace en proyectos de
petróleo gas O carbón hoy sábado Cuando
llegamos al Ecuador de esta cumbre de
cambio climático en salmelsake el premio
es para ha ido para Estados Unidos
gringolandia justamente le han caído
porque aquí en los negociaciones están
bloqueando todo sin declarar muy bien
con Claridad su posicionamiento y sobre
todo están dejando de mover la mecanismo
muy importante para dar dinero a la
gente impactado por el cambio climático
y cómo se siente con este premio Es un
honor
otro de los países que comparten el muro
da son por ejemplo Rusia Egipto y el
próximo anfitrión de la 28 emiratos
árabes Unidos
esto en las noticias buenas noches
[Música]